I'm joined now by Edwin Morgan he's the
director of policy at the Institute of
Directors so Edwin Jeremy Corbyn says
he's in the mainstream so as business
yet to catch up with him I mean I think
the only thing the business can say
about that speech today was yeah we know
not the flavor of the month with the
labor leader we've we've accepted that
but we were hoping that you were maybe
throw out a bone and a knowledge the
importance of business yet people have
different views exactly how you regulate
how you tax but at the basic level
without businesses we have the millions
of businesses largest mall in this
country there's no taxes to farm
property services there's no jobs yeah
the economy would crumble so I think
we're just looking for a little bit more
little bit of positivity at least on
yeah businesses and they were working
together well I mean you mentioned
working together I mean the CBI has said
that where it has tried to engage with
labor it has met with some sort of
response see are you saying that hasn't
been the IO DS experience well I mean
actually what was kind of disappointing
about today was that there was a clash
between what happens if you talk to a
Labour MPs well actually there's a lot
of common ground on skills in particular
you know they've made a real push on
lifelong learning and that was in the
speech but you know there was nothing
about how we're if we're gonna adapt to
the millions of jobs that are going to
be lost because of automation you need
to bring businesses with you because you
can't the government can't do that on
its own so a bit more from from the
leader that actually we do hear from
from a lot of MPs on how can we work
together better on that so in other
words you're saying that Labour MPs are
far more pro-business than the Labour
leadership I don't know that as
universally true certainly from today's
speech yeah we were looking for more I
think I think that's point you know we
understand this is politics he's
speaking to the people in the hall but
you know they kept saying we're with the
party we were ready for government if
they get into government they are going
to have to engage more positively more
constructively with business that's just
a fact but isn't a problem for business
I mean some of the things that Corbin
was outlining today such as taxing
undeveloped land a lot of people say
well hang on that's entirely reasonable
that there are lots of things that were
raised today where a lot of people might
agree with but we have seen a lot of
detail on a lot of it the PFI
suggestions made by the Shadow
Chancellor yesterday that they would all
be brought in house now
a little bit more like he's just saying
we'll review some of them so I think a
lot of this is is goes the way it's done
clearly they want headlines but if you
want to reassure investors if you want
to say look actually you know we can
make sure the economy it continues to be
strong these things have to be thought
through and they have to be implemented
carefully and you know business isn't
going to like everything but at least if
it can be brought along a bit of the way
so there isn't panic that would really
help all right ed we're Morgan from the
Institute of Directors thanks for
joining me good see